the hotel terrace stinks but without
the Pileck you pull years of heavy rain
and it was the taste of victory heart
folders dick dsdiff and stories in amazing
siri
if you want to show
hitler i want to show you the place where
ministerial lake grew up few people know
about it in kiwi and who knows don’t know what’s in
it especially we have our own little
world with its own rules son thunder
doesn’t at all
[music]
analytics nebo7 ken  block 7 setting up the
base, well, first of all, where they go more than one
pood of transport, so we should
walk for two to see the
sights around us
why we are so secretive,
it’s hard for us to get there during the Soviet
Union, the cabinet of ministers was formed there
people they built dug this lake of
atoms were born  and built houses as
service personnel as a result of the collapse of the
Soviet Union, well, how
would such a mothballed
arthur society remain  a swarm of samus to herself there
are some rules you will come up with and then the police live according to
them
, according to the accounts, it doesn’t get to the city,
in principle, we’re far away
for a man, not on foot, on foot, by bike
bean, how it turned out in winter, it’s generally
unrealistic to reach and dangerous, in principle,
often the verses of the seeder are making
whole train maxis parade series batch
file
ball descried don't care well
myself sometimes afraid to go here risks it's a
joke it's a joke no serious
[laugh]
serious city with vanilla you don't tepe
buefar mr k
frame types
on paper know u get lost moved effire
early  in the morning I don’t even know what drives them
at this moment
so set fire just burned all the
dry grass you showed it will seem
fun
[music]
this is Mr. yes this is actually the entrance to
me doing laundry at home now I will ask the guys I
will go to security because they might not
miss the hand I’ll find the same
state guard, they know all the locals
and naturally the local misses
our angry and you started me so much  oh what
do Irina's place think about either its
default by other listings I would sing
the playoffs from google maps
not with me the essence of the change to reach hundreds of
three would you aim at ags and bars march
my pulse to say junkies want
insistent very
naturally now I'm future there  a year and a
half sober, we understand somewhere remotely a
darning
happened, and with this
without is wonderful
shar-pei
maxim was on whom he was declared an enemy, I
dreamed of filling him up and just finishing him off a
single ready for a long time began to be friends
when I lied came to life in the hands of a weapon and
you are ready to do  I don’t know by what miracle
evil I found myself in the center didn’t commit
an irreversible act the
former children’s hospital is already abandoned
there, as it were, they are already resting, let’s say
people are the last stage of it and the crying
bath and and the caption and where are the mega
lucky cats splits like my place hands up
like to  play and spa lago
microcar x
I myself can write it sounds better than
Evgeniy in the class I don’t want anyone to get
into an awkward situation once again
mother, I don’t know how
it’s possible, it’s not at all the private
territory of the falling one, I have this
memory of which is connected precisely with
this place, which I don’t want to insert, but
I’m not ready yet, of
course, it all happened by fraud,
because he wouldn’t go on his own,
although he said
he simply  I realized that daf punk got for nothing
now right in front of me suddenly the
axis of the cone that first day when I
came here at night completely broken I
don’t know
what it is and on the site right with the hands of the
geranium guys
[music]
it’s possible to just take and change
never 30 days  you start anew
40 what difference does it make the world just
for me my friend aamir starts to come off
and the exhibition visited pictures of
me it is very important many guys I know
since childhood they go on a slope and tactics
I didn’t realize what they were doing
if this is a video thanks although to the tank
love, I’m
not in vain
I tell you
[music
] actually this is a very old oak tree I
came here to think he resorted to
jogging
not very impressed  silt oak there is something to
think about under this oak let's just say that there is
such strength in
it somehow it seems to me really there
has been a lot of
all sorts of struggles personally with myself it’s
not a stone’s throw away I stopped by and ran away
just a beautiful place
[music]
we hope
max you are a strong person
gives strength but I
love and care of loved ones no not
necessarily it's mom dad people who
meet such a card that everything is a
mage katkova I hear these words all the time
you're bad your own was bad then
something good and I want to thank you
[music]
[music  ]